Copy and paste lets you take text from one place and put it somewhere else.
For instance, say you're on a website and there's a really great paragraph that you want to send.
Select the paragraph by clicking before the first word,...
...holding the mouse button down,...
...and then dragging the mouse until just after the last word in the paragraph.
All the text will become highlighted so you'll know it's selected.
Next, you have to tell your computer that you want to copy it.
Click on the edit menu from the top of your screen,...
...then select copy.
Now the paragraph is stored and ready to be pasted.
Next, open up your e-mail and compose a new message.
Click your mouse where you want to paste the text,...
...then click on edit at the top of the screen, and then select paste.
And voila! The paragraph has now been copied and pasted.
I hope this helps, and I look forward to getting e-mails from you soon.